[Musique]
comme un air du
davant au programme du concert test
d'hier soir à bercy
le groupe indochine on a travaillé pour
essayer de prouver de montrer que en
prenant un certain nombre de précautions
on pourra retrouver cette vie normale un
début à 17 heures pour finir à 20h30
dans la fosse les spectateurs masqué
testés et tous négatifs avaient entre 18
et 45 ans pour la première fois depuis
janvier
moins de 3000 patients sont actuellement
en réanimation le cap des 25 millions de
primo vacciner a également été dépassé
et la campagne se poursuit en
s'élargissant à tous les majeurs sans
distinction d'âge dès demain diriez que
la crise du coït 19 et enfin derrière
nous alors moi je dis que la vaccination
c'est évidemment un atout formidable
pour sortir de cette crise sanitaire il
faut rester très prudent parce que tout
le monde n'est pas vacciné aujourd'hui
et puis il faut rester vigilant aussi
sur les variants en tant que femme à 21h
je ne serais pas rentré chez moi parce
que c'est dangereux
donc on vous demande à vous et c'est
quoi la solution la solution je veux
dire 1 d'abord volonté politique où on a
envie on n'a pas envie si c'est lui qui
se retrouve au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle face à marine le pen
c'est elle qui l'emportera parce qu'il a
rallumé de la haine sociale dans notre
pays qui créera un rejet personnel quand
bien même les gens n'ont pas franchement
envie de marine le pen
il ya quelqu'un qui accompagne ce piteux
juste derrière si vous faites dont vous
allez allez voir et vous allez voir ils
sont en train de se piquer bientôt les
divertit vente libre m'annonce qu'on ne
voyait pas avant 2 110 gendarmes dont le
gign déployés pour encercler petit à
petit cet homme d'une trentaine d'années
qui a voulu s'en prendre à son ex
compagne il se cache dans les bois
entourant le village un monde mais à
force de ne rien vouloir traiter de ne
pas me nommer les choses on règle rien
et ça devient effectivement la guerre ce
n'est pas une fiction nous sommes bien
en politique et non pas en cours d'école
en 2021
regardez ce qu'ils aient donc réellement
passé hier
[Applaudissements]
le couple agressé parvient à se mettre à
l'abri avec les enfants l'assaillant
connu pour des faits de violences
conjugales lui vise les gendarmes
notamment ce véhicule avant de partir se
cacher dans la forêt il n'y a pas eu de
blessés alors que le président de la
région grand est jean rottner candidats
aient l'air à sa réélection vient d'être
aspergés de farine alors qu'il quittait
un rassemblement pour la défense des
langues régionales regarder le député lr
jacques qu'atteindre ici en veste de
costume grise et chemise bleue colistier
de jean rottner se jette sur christian
zimmermann qui est en train de filmer
gens rentrent nerfs plein de farine
l'homme est un ancien militaire du
régime ont de brive armé de deux
carabines et d'un couteau il a tiré sur
trois véhicules et un hélicoptère de
gendarmerie
les autorités demandent aux 1400
habitants de l'art d'un salazar de
rester confinés à leur domicile
le sri lanka a lancé une enquête
aujourd'hui après l'incendié d'un
porte-conteneurs au large de ses côtes
elle cela fait 11 jours maintenant que
le navire brûle l' incendie n'est pas
éteint mais il est maîtrisé
la plus grande catastrophe
environnementale dans cette région de
l'océan indien selon les scientifiques
sur place à bord de ce porte containers
au feu une cargaison hautement toxiques
et polluante 25 tonnes d'acide citrique
elles se sont déversés au maire
localement la faune et la flore sous
marines sont largement détruite en toute
discrétion le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson 56 ans est
marié à sa fiancée carrie simons 33 ans
avec laquelle il a eu un enfant l'an
passé